oh go ahead and go live
okay four people joining this livestream
this is a warm language design review
about a rather naughty topic that has
been on the horizon for a long time
which is the conflict between doing math
right and doing maths the way people
will expect if they are studying math
and elementary level so quintessential
example square root of x-squared
many people would expect that that would
just give X but by default it doesn't
just give X in our system now how will
we get that to give X if we were
absolute value of X is what I would
expect over the reals well okay but
let's see what we do to get this to give
what's the minimum path to getting this
to budget is greater equals zero the
other way around right and then you have
to refine them why try simplifies that
because assuming refine go together
simplifies sort of a one-shot then you
have to turn it around together yes okay
so we already lost the game here I mean
this is way way too complicated you know
since we're trying to service elementary
users here okay so so let's take a look
at what for each of these cases and what
the generalizations of these guys by the
way we've got background noise oh and um
the for each of these cases what and
what additional cases are there for each
of these cases what do you need to get
out of it and you know what's the issue
so to speak okay so can we can we
categorize these cases so this is what
is this case this is basically
fractional powers right is this is this
this along with this one which we have
solved that one we've solved by having a
cube root log log and power or you know
in elementary math those are the ones
that really come up the most I think all
of your cases is that more or less oh
it's okay
let's clatter go ahead log issues and
then we've got powers also this normos
you but it's not the same as the as a
power issue no it's it's a non analytic
Ness okay
okay so this is so we have a third one
there this one on it like the complex
component the ABS REM those guys right
no no let's yesterday although that's
clarity that's the symptom I mean so
what are you saying for conjugate when
you have expressions that involve re M
conjugate yeah right right
okay I do did but I mean what would you
expect this to do would you expect this
to do something reasonable or not I will
eventually expect this to implement
what's called the CR calculus which does
allow for differentiability over the
reals but it's not analytically
differentiable so it's correctly not but
yeah you mean like Koshi Riemann is that
what CR stands for something no complex
real I see so it's introduced normally
in multivariate complex analysis and in
a very few univariate complex analysis
books does that gives you
differentiability beyond these analytic
okay ocean yeah what is it called CR
calculus okay and what does it what will
that make this look like it would make
you you know because like if say that
you have an expert a that you're gonna
optimize an expression with complex
variables in it now you basically want
to differentiate it with respect to the
real and imaginary parts yes
this gives you tools to do that at the
matrix level you know the univariate I
have a vector level matrix okay that
sounds interesting but I think you know
we're not even at the complex number
level here no dealing with I mean what
I'm talking about here I'm trying to
remember what issues I've had recently I
thought I had sent them through to
everybody I they seem to not be here um
[Music]
oh that somebody has got a bunch of
background noise um I think once
nobody's on mute so it's confusing to me
okay um the one thing that we have done
is that we've introduced so this is kind
of almost an experiment but we
introduced to one called relapse I don't
know on it one is called them okay so
let's list solutions that we've had so
far solutions so far to this so one
thing to assert to be clear on in
mathematica you know version three or so
maybe even version four didn't even know
how to do anything over the reals
everything was a hundred percent sort of
a CI I I understand I understand so what
we have done is to introduce real you
know so we can solve over the reals we
can simplify over the reals so there's a
lot of but it's not automatic so I'm
saying that the default assumption has
not sort of changed
I understand that but I'm you know the
issue is we're trying to solve the
problems yes yeah no no I'm just there
okay so let's look at these cases right
because the main problem is okay so
first question is first question would
be um you know what signals of
elementary Ness do we have so I'm saying
so for example the presence of units
that would be one example of an of a way
that you know we pretty much know we're
not dealing with complex numbers when we
have units involved it a little bit
would be a little bit careful like
making an exponential I answered it's
very common even for symbol oscillation
problems okay all right okay fine but
there's specific patterns there but
that's a so you know again I want to
know what signals of elementary miss do
we have I thought it's the first most
important one is the value of the name
how do you well I see what you're saying
so and see sort of interpreted as
complex or no no no that if it's if it's
some okay so this is real but w.c is
probably not real at least
probabilistically I see right we found
by the way when you gave us benchmark
theta when people type limits and they
use N or K they probably mean discrete
limits sure right and that's a wolf now
for style thing um but that's not
something we can use here but okay so
okay so what other signals of elementary
nests do we have in other words when
somebody is trying to do this
computation right I mean I know I was
being driven crazy by some of these
computations like this one here what was
I doing I was doing something that
involved
yeah I think I I mean I think when this
base X is a unit of quantity you know if
this is a certain number of meters or
something then that's a signal isn't it
I agree but really does one race a
quantity vez dimensions to a symbolic
okay okay fair enough but but but in
this case okay fine fine fine I forget
what I was doing I may have been doing
something which will only be done once
in the history of physics or something
so I think I'm getting to what you're
potentially thinking of is that there
should be an automatic domain choice or
something I don't know I don't know
whether that's where I'm going but I'm I
don't know I I think that's gonna be
difficult right I don't think that's the
right gonna be hard to predict for a
user I know I know I know I thought yes
kind of like it or it made me try to
have a clovis which yes I realized that
and I mean I think that um it's you know
you know a potential solution right
potential solutions you know let's say a
function called you know elementary form
or something bad name but you get what
I'm saying so elementary form of square
root of x squared is X okay something
like that something like n you see what
I'm saying I think public funds with the
due to vast majority of what you had
mentioned so far but nobody's going to
know to do that that's good
you know that's it's not the right
packaging right so okay so you're
claiming the power expand would do these
things I don't know would it I mean
let's try this power expand of log X Y
okay did that one what about this one
this one you're dead in the water
yeah it doesn't deal with solvers power
expand
four expressions right so as so is
elementary form fine
okay so then then it would be all all
and they know what to do is in salsa
sorry I mean it could be holds all but
but I mean - wait a minute I'll go then
that's four expressions and then the
question is what four solvers means
you're ethically as only 50% joking
theoretically elementary form could be
hold all and then propagates relevant
information down sleep like whenever you
have elementary form crept around then
you call a salt and you don't have a
third argument is it audience or
argument is what is this really I mean
it's basically is it elementary algebra
is it what what is the what is the
correct characterization of what it is
we're talking about here or is it
something more specific as at positive
reals what what are we actually talking
about here Adam but if there's probably
save for the vast majority of things but
when Ken Wahby could instruct counter
examples okay roughly positive reals
okay
on our live stream Muhammad is
suggesting one at a global variable I
think because we we we hate global
variables because people never know when
it's set it's somewhere way away from
where you are in the notebook I mean to
me if we did that okay so so hold on
let's just look at this for a second
let's imagine that I mean just like we
say something like you know I don't know
it's almost like a locale you don't like
whoever okay but look at this okay if we
set it in such a way that it would say
slash slash elementary form on every
output other words if it was a wrapper
around everything and it always said
elementary form here
if you think it doesn't quite fit with
our current paradigm of star form falls
no it does not it does not it's not it's
not that so I don't think it's but slash
slash elementary or some such other
thing if that's what the so it here's
another question I mean in in that you
know no unfortunately wouldn't wouldn't
fit for another reason right because it
isn't it isn't a rapper it's not like
out sixty is set to the underlying
square root of x squared out sixty is
set to X you see what I'm saying yes
exactly right which am
yeah whatever it is right but I mean
it's it's so that's not the right thing
but so now um but roughly the thing we'd
like to be able to show is mmm could
imagine a rapper that's that's not a
form star form function but it's a
rapper and
and it's wrap-around expressions yeah
and it just follows along oh you know
actually that's a mess because it's
abstract yeah everything's so messed up
right and and you know and it's again
it's then a calculus of annotations
problem you don't know when you yes you
know anyway yeah um so but but okay so
first question is I mean let's imagine
so s WS a China live stream is just
suggesting dollar pre equals elementary
yeah I mean let's is it sufficient if we
had a function let's imagine we have the
function elementary whatever whatever
whatever it is right we understand
there's an issue with solvers there
might have to be a whole wall story etc
etc etc I'm not sure how that would work
um you know it's kind of a scoping
construct but could we so it would be a
scooping construct where we have to
figure out the variables at one time
causal didn't expect it existed
otherwise it gets too inconvenient I
agree
I see so what you're saying is I mean
the default version okay so one
possibility would be um you know that
the full version would be elementary you
know X Y Z I don't really like this blah
blah blah and that the default version
is elementary sort of automatic what
well I'm just saying maybe you don't
want this to apply to every variable Oh
silly idea and what do you imagine to be
in place of X's
an expression that is evaluated with the
elementary assumption so to speak mm-hmm
right well
with those variable means mean like
there are the ones that if you had an a
that wasn't listed look it's it's
probably not a good idea it's just
riffing on the scoping construct concept
so I'm saying because you know in other
words if a wasn't included there
then whatever transformations we make
with A's wouldn't participate in this
elementra fication I mean I I still the
calculus of elementary education I don't
fully understand right and I I mean
you're basically saying that it's pretty
much assumed positive reals is that a
good working assumption some water or or
or the other way of looking at is issues
sort of you use transformations that are
taught in certain grade school and and
do not worry about don't worry about the
assumptions that that's pretty much it
would be so it's well yes I agree but so
I want to know what what transformations
are taught that are not simply assume
all variables are positive in real some
of them must would assume that that
variables are integers I guess like
exponents would be integers often
explain that so we really need to
understand this I'm trying to figure out
what was the goods in fractional roots
is a potential example explain where
often times and fashion up fractional
roots are introduced you they're
introduced with an assumption that
you're talking about the real valued
root oh for sure yes right but but okay
that was different from wait we're
saying I'm confused by that you mean X
to the one-third specifically or you
mean or you mean X to the a where a is
assumed to be a fractional a rational
number I'm talking about X to the
one-third say okay right okay that's a
good that's a good case because we have
a solution as you know to that but that
so this is where it actually have is it
what does it oh we have cube root and we
also have third right yes
okay but so the issue is that yeah
that's a really good point because the
issue is if somebody types X to the one
third in elementary mode
what the heck do we do you see what I'm
saying because because it's already too
late right so X to the one third how
would we untangle that what okay let me
ask this question if we say minus X to
the one third okay and we are in
elementary mode what what does that does
that have some different meaning
that means it's minus times X to the one
third doesn't it yes so so the thing
with integer assumptions
between something like x times y to the
power n well people would expect it to
be X to the N times y to the N and and
they wouldn't be given me absolutely
crazy yes yes so how do I get that one
right now how do I make that one work
right now because I don't even know I
mean you see okay let me explain how
I've run into this so I'm doing sort of
physics e engineering Li calculations
right I'm not thinking I'm doing pure
math and you know x and y are I don't
know you know the radius of an electron
or something which is nonzero in the
modern world
um the and you know there's nothing
potentially branch Cutty or anything
about it it's just you know it's just a
you know you get what I'm saying so I
don't wanna have to think about Oh under
what circumstances is this true this
power explained do it yeah I think so it
does but power explained assumes that
everything is positive real but it's not
enough yes here what power expect but I
I think and should be real at least by
the fairness it's not obvious to me if n
is fractional is that obviously true for
all x and y for x and y that are
positive
yes okay let me ask another question is
raised by something on that live stream
is there only one elementary set of
assumptions or other several in other
words is it is it either your elementary
or you're not or is it you know well you
do this in grade school you do this in
high school you do this in college type
thing right there probably might be some
level levels of it yeah we need to
analyze that because it's important to
the design I mean how many you know cuz
that's gonna get very very messy if
there is significant I mean you know cuz
we could also take the point of view if
you go and say Elementary you're going
to the most elementary level okay can
anybody think of an intermediate case so
all fingers formulas okay let's get that
let me let me write that down
okay so um intermediate levels so what
why me none in terms of what we come up
with here I have other things that
basically relate to default assumptions
that I want to not have anymore
so for instance one assumption that we
have in the system is that a symbol is a
complex variable or that you know from
my point of view I don't care so much
complex or real but that it's scalar I
want it to be vector or matrix so that's
I understand so that's in question yeah
so but that has a similar insidious
thing right even more general in eg X is
a vector variable right
okay can we uh what the half angle
formula issue is Michael you wanted to
go to something like spear with the fun
minors course or something like this but
this is of course only a lot of
conditions on Ted are correct can you
tell me how I would get to that point I
think your talent is no dinos come off
now for do it was good Sean's
um you can get it in two steps I mean
you can do trig yeah
yes expand or trig reduce and then solve
for whatever you want
another class I feel like that follows
from this that might be useful sorry did
I did I did it not do it or did I just
type the wrong thing in I think you have
to ask for it okay
like IndyCars like in T cause people
that want this kind of simplification
say ones many integers in terms of
arctan also 10 lakhs
so you're saying integral of X 1 over x
squared minus X something exactly does a
6 loss I was thinking that's complicated
but it is family of things yeah in that
family that those those arctan formulas
are usually full of discontinuities so
you don't have to be careful about those
you know so if you have a big long
formula full of our accounts it if you
plot it it look horrible because it's
just full of discontinuities
which which sorry with this thing here
as a no no not this one but but but when
you do this I mean this is something
that will I think we can we can we can
create a discontinuity free formula
basically or minimized so on so your
goal here is so what we are doing we are
trying to create a discontinuity at
minimal discontinuity no we're not in
the future we will we might be trying to
yeah in the future but but right now
that's not the case they there are a
bunch of Architects coming out but it
produces lots and lots of
discontinuities that's a really good
criterion now Roger yeah you know
discontinuity minimizing formulas right
okay did Michael have to go home maybe
he already dropped out yeah okay um so
this one I don't even know what the
formula is myself I'm embarrassed to say
but just I mean it's gonna be sort of
one minus cos squared what am i say one
I was just say one of them is it if
that's sine oh sorry sorry if you pop
the alpha page it it'll show it among
some of the many alternate forms here
there's this 2 times sine times cosine
if you click the more button there's
probably more forms there that somebody
was saying there's a square root form
there should be a square root form right
I mean there surely it's fairly
complicated I think having to do with
the sign that having to do with the sine
of theta
maybe we don't care so I mean this is
something completely different but but
that's only true apparently for some
small I mean they're clearly other
I mean look that as we get to other
levels right we're clearly going to have
things like log minus X I don't know
what that's supposed to do what's that
supposed to do I mean
what what should that do if anything
maybe nothing
Roger Adam probably nothing it sort of
with the assumption that X is positive
it actually makes it explicitly complex
so well what can you do is it um okay
fine all right let's come back to our
original problem okay so what we've got
are certain certain things including
solvers okay first point is the first
working assumption because nobody you
know the dominant issue is going to be
elementary or not elementary there may
be some shades in the middle but those
are the ones that we should make easy do
we agree so kind of so the I ever you
know Adam brought this up and it's
slightly inconsistent but one thing
that's kind of easy right now is that
you solve you know you know you give the
variable and comma reals that for the
most part will do what you want hmm
with it's not equally simple for
simplified because you have to say which
variables are real so it's like a more
typing but if it's not just real it's
it's positive as well we have with but
we can expand that to be positive reals
we have a symbol called positive reals
or non-negative reals whatever but let's
say that you introduce let's say that we
can figure out what it is maybe we could
have it's not really a domain in the
sense of a mathematical set but it's
like what the sumption z-- to make
because those the reals and complex is a
really sort of assumption to make when
solving simplifying well what you're
saying is that this is like having
assuming by the way does assuming
assuming is a scoping construct to the
point where we could say assuming if I
say assuming X greater than 0 solve 2 to
the X equals 8 I think so why only
affects things that have assumptions
optioning done and why doesn't solve it
should it's really something further
it's it's not quite trivial to in
so we well it just would take some time
so there it so this has been a remnant
because Adam has a different way of
doing it here the problem is that it
breaks the uniform nests of all
workflows so been pushing for it to have
an assumptions option but solve to have
an assumptions option right we can you
can I think it makes sense but but let's
just write out the right today you can
express everything because you can put
the assumptions in the equation terms
saying how you just say X greater than 0
and X greater than 0 in that solve right
so that the assumptions issue would be
that you use assumptions when it's
convenient for you not always solve them
if you put them here you you just will
you just solve the assumptions so
complex functions is just available but
not necessarily used so you have to
support that yeah ok but fine but but
that says there's a you know by the time
we're actually doing the algorithmic
part of this we kind of understand how
to do it
is you what you're basically saying
we're gonna assume positive reals we're
gonna assume that every symbolic
variable is a positive real right I I
wonder whether in the elementary world
and again this is something I don't know
and I you know I'm hoping we can really
study could they ever be negative reals
you know you're solving an equation
right
I mean clearly they could be negative
reals in some cases they probably
couldn't be they couldn't be complexes
but negative numbers you know in certain
cases you actually wanted to come out in
terms of negative numbers in other cases
you implicitly wanted to be positive
because you know there's some big messy
thing with logarithms of negative
numbers or whatever you don't want to
get into am I making sense right so yeah
it's even more complicated cincy so one
of the examples you send was was one
where you had parameters so you may want
to assume a lot of things about
parameters to make the solving part easy
can you give me what my example was
because I thought ok that was gonna be
part of the meeting ok I think it was
some power thing
yeah okay but so there is a okay what
we're basically saying is there's a
fairly complicated axiomatic system
basically that represents elementary
math okay and I think we don't
understand if it's even self consistent
I suspect well I agree that that's one
of the issues right that's one of the
issues and I think ultimately it will
not be consistent but that we have to be
okay with that just like ultimately
branch cuts are not really consistent
why not well I mean we're going to make
some definite assumption about some you
know you know logarithm is the solution
to whatever well okay if you ignore the
message generated by solve that says
branch cuts are you know this this
solution involves branch cuts then you
will get things where well I guess it
will always solve the equation but it
may do other weird things right but yes
you are to some extent I mean Michael
would probably are I mean but from my
point of view branch cut choices is a
human historical affair you know Michael
would argue that they're pretty
consistently done while she set power
and log everything else is going to be
relatively consistent with that
I yeah I don't know how consistent and I
you know I mean there's pretty
complicated branch cut structures there
are okay but and we're getting up to
very general functions now with power
and so on doesn't really you know play
comment on livestream are saying that
the solution will be seamless
multivalued function interface I don't
know what that means I don't yeah I
think that's [ __ ]
I don't think that there is such a thing
can we before you steal all your
conscience is not a function to begin
with so and I don't think anybody's
figured out how to implement that well I
understand that can we just take one
minute you know I've this is a this is a
40-year issue as far as I'm concerned of
how do you do this like square roots and
things you know is there any meaningful
way to carry around a alternatives
object that represents the I mean of
course with logarithm it's an infinite
number but that represents the the stack
of possibilities I mean you know by the
time we've got things like around sort
of wish Michael was here because he's
thinking about that so well okay but but
let's let's well we would probably have
to have a follow-up meeting here um but
but I mean so then another case is
carrying around multiple values um so in
other words where it's called you know
multivalued or something and it says
minus one plus one or some such other
thing you know where we say square root
of square root of one goes to this
multivalued object is that obviously
completely crazy Roger pretty close to I
think in why because the parameter
figure we have Noah because I think it
will explode in complexity very very
quickly well I mean like probability
distributions do but that's still not
useless right I mean in other words the
question is is
I agree it's going to be combinatorial
in terms of its explosion of I mean in
it and I doubt that much will merge
therefore making sense I mean one would
have to try to work through such a
solution and see what it like I'm
sceptical about when there are
parameters in there I think it could get
unbelievably you know deep algebraic
geometry basically yeah and it's way
beyond algebraic geometry because you
know for those transcendental functions
it's sure yes okay fair enough but I'm
I'm saying when there are parameters it
looks very very hairy um but I don't
think that that would again and don't
think it solves well okay this is the
sort of intermediate level case where
people are saying well you know the
square root of four might be -2 what
stage in like like see I'm concerned
that there's a a stage of school where
the square root of four is two and
there's a scale at a stage of school
where it's plus or minus two and I don't
quite know what the consequences of
allowing plus or minus two are does
anybody have a comment on that Jeremy
maybe I think generally
I think that there is not a if the if
any there's not a long period where the
square root of 2 a 4 is just 2 I think
the way you write them even in
elementary books they write plus minus
square root I mean - this is true
you know so they write both of them out
this knot or if you're doing something
like song let's say it was that it was
you know what's the square root of 3 so
that doesn't have a closed form they
would write out plus minus square root
of 3 square root of 3 itself was two
values okay but what you're describing
is math stuff if you were doing
engineering you're not interested in the
negative square root typically so again
we come back to what what what the
British notion of engineering is sort of
more elementary i I know that yes we're
not talking Swedish engineering Roger no
but I'm just saying this complex numbers
are heavily used in in in EE you know
and of course they all right but I'm
talking about look I'm talking about
somebody a cop carpentry okay Mike's
carpentry you're not dealing with
negative length pieces of wood yeah
rarely right and so let's let me say
carpentry rather than engineering
well I'm when I'm wanting to describe
this some um okay so this was my example
um this is a log issue basically well it
may be it's a power issue this one here
this drove me crazy yeah this thing is
just that's bonkers right it just went
off into lala land right so the solution
is arbitrary complexity and these it's
really complicated let's just forget it
no I never waited long enough but yeah I
mean this is completely crazy it's
completely crazy
what if you say reals come a reals it's
too complicated
comma reals here is two out applicated
well what happens if I say positive
reals
oh that that doesn't work as a domain
actually why not uh what does that -
well well what is this claim they seem
we also here
Oh actually I guess it's it's well I
guess I forgot about it so it actually
has assumption that everything is a
positive real where everything is a
variable so it is you know if we really
go to this format is that if should be
gray or something I agree I'm more
stylized not in the same font item I
think that's just to fix that thing okay
it's etai but but in it but if it can do
with some feedback we had a lot of
feedback before and there was a lot of
opinions but now that it's out we see it
in action more I mean it's nice it's
generally nice but um okay so so I mean
yeah this is another case okay so so
la-la-land case right cases where
basically you know you get what I'm
saying where that case is a different
thing you know you could be into this
it's like I was doing this it's like
what the heck is going on here this is
trivial you know why am i you know why
I'm why am i messing around with this
see what I'm saying hmm and by the time
it's gone into this you know oh I can't
even solve it I mean I at least want to
see a message telling me how to get to
something reasonable here yeah rather
than just sorry you know I can't solve
it even though it it's Elementary right
I mean I could do it in my head I mean
it's crazy right so I see it actually
does does give you such a shunter solve
over the rails well Murray Mouse's
oh I never look at that well light I'll
run with it on but it didn't do anything
over the reals but it can so that wasn't
useful so that there's multiple bugs
here so in addition to that the
suggestions line isn't useful either but
it's nice that there was a suggestions
line I mean that's probably a case yeah
I mean okay silly me for not looking at
that um I mean right so okay so there's
a question mark here use suggestions bar
in other words for cases where that's
actually interesting let me see what
this does for example does this ever
reasonable so no that's useless right so
so that's a that's a good point and
possibly something where we can have a
promoted suggestion here in a different
color or something right to resolve this
I think they are hard to rights because
they can only observe the output mmm I
switch sang and well they are you so
evident that they can only observe the
output I know for Wayne we did you know
there they also get the input right but
I think here it's not self-evident to me
that they can't do something just by
looking at the output I mean it's the
thing to analyze I think okay so that's
a that's a I'm just let's look at some
potential solutions okay I'm just gonna
add this here to potential solutions is
a phrase tense you know an awful lot
here you know if one could say simplify
comma positive reals I'm not interested
that's too complicated
okay it's too complicated irrelevant I
mean we've got to have a way to do this
so that for elementary users
fundamentally they can be in a mode
which is easy to understand what that
what's going on where it is just
doing elementary stuff telling them oh
you got to go simplify over the positive
reals you lost the game right so then
the question is it's like is if so
someone suggested a global variable
which is sort of kind of what we're
talking about in a mode yes it is but
but I don't know how to implement that
but but okay look there are two levels
of this okay first level is can we
package it so that it's you know slash
slash elementary or something okay once
we've got it packaged like that
switching on elementary by default I can
imagine ways to do that
making sense yeah that's similar to the
real only assumption we have in Wayne
fair enough
the other thing that I was thinking
about so that the way to do that you
know since we probably can't do tackle
every saw over in one go is what I'm
thinking about this sort of though that
what we have done would these domain
generalize the notion of domain to kind
of be automatic or something adder that
isn't a mathematical domain which is
more sure you know signals it how to
behave no I think that's right I I don't
think it should be called positive reals
I just don't think because that's not
the whole story I think we need a notion
of the you know elementary rules apply
or something I don't know exactly how
that works but the question is you know
look there's there's two levels of this
one is let's say we have the elementary
packaging okay then what is that
packaging turn into algorithmically and
as you say is it even consistent right
and we we got to know the answer to that
because if it isn't consistent doesn't
mean we can't do it there plenty of
things we do which are not really
consistent as in you know zero times X
to zero right you know and and clearly
effects is you know I mean there's
there's if effects subsequently becomes
infinity then where our luck right but
they're things like that that one has to
do and I don't think there's anything I
personally not that scared about
inconsistency in the elementary math
case because I think yes there will be
but but that's why people go on and
learn more advanced math I mean it's
okay um but I think the important thing
is okay so I mean I would say that the
right approach is something where we
package it as this something like this
elementary thing um but what would that
be I still AM it's a wrapper okay so it
might be called let's let's move it is a
wrapper so it's hangs around but no I
didn't mean I didn't mean that I didn't
mean that I mean I mean it's a dollar
pre thing let's say it's called
elementary evaluate okay and it's a
whole thing that goes by some trickery
um the UM and goes in and rewrites the
solves and all that kind of thing and
essentially if you're if you're using
you know elementary evaluate okay so for
somebody like me who most of the time
wants the full fanciness right then I
would know that when I'm in a situation
like this I would try this and our gosh
it doesn't work then I would say let me
do elementary evaluate on this a little
bit like the way I would say do n on
something you know what I'm saying you
know if the integral if I can't get the
integral analytically I just say n of it
and I'm you know and it'll produce
something so I mean I think
that's the cognitive flow now in terms
of elementary users
it might okay so you know there are a
couple of different arguments for the
most elementary users they're going to
be using wolf now if a notebook Edition
almost certainly they don't even going
to be using this and um ah now I mean
let's remind ourselves why is this
taking forever to start up what's going
on here what is going on that's weird
okay so let's remind ourselves how this
works so here where's the real only
assumption is that in here yes
try using real numbers only so in other
words if I say square of x squared here
AB sex
however goodness sake that's a fail if I
might say so it is cetera it's used in
swimming yeah I think it's something in
the solvers well this should be I'm
sorry but this is wrong I mean you
should get that fixed um
and
say oops if I say up here
try using real numbers only and I do
that you're saying it's not going to
affect this laughs okay yeah I think oh
by the way there's a some nice wsh is
pointing out a something weird here
let's take a look at this this is a soul
that's you again x equals T squared and
X is greater than zero
what why isn't that T equal square root
of x huh sorry at some generousity
assumption yeah that's that's probably
some generousity assumption so for
generic complex actually doesn't have
solutions
oh goodness sake well it's consistent
yeah but it's wrong I mean that's the
problem right so if you say over reals
you should get something there okay okay
look look we've got this is a big mess
okay we've really got to solve this
really got to solve this
right so that for generate complex acts
you don't have positive solutions okay
how many more of these okay how do we
find all of these things right so I mean
for example here if our elementary
rapper basically sprayed positive reals
assumptions into all the solves it would
correctly do this correct yes
unfortunately positive reals doesn't
work with this why not it returns the
same as reals why well so positive reals
that is that just a bug or what which
one no no your Jeremy is saying that
positive reals doesn't do the right
thing in this case how it works it is
the same thing as in 75 though what's
wrong with that oh I see I see I see I
see I see why is it giving an assumption
it shouldn't be giving an assumption she
just say tears
it just should say T is square root of x
everything's positive real so there is
no solve this assumption is a condition
you solved it for for X being positive
entity being positive so your solution
includes the condition that that's wrong
okay that's wrong it should not there's
always include there's no reason to
include the assumption in the output I
just want the solution T is square root
of x I don't want it to have this crazy
conditional on some conditional
expression I already told it the
conditional expression I said resolve it
by saying assuming everything is
positive real right so there is there is
no assumption so you solve it it's a
condition meaning okay so it's wrong
Adam it's wrong let's write ok so
there's nothing more to say about it
it's it's a it's a bug and it should get
fixed so I mean the correct answer here
is T is square root of x is there any
problem with that
No okay good alright um that's what you
would get if you refine or simplified it
under those same assumptions all right
or or if if self had the assumptions
option and it was actually kinda
assumption right so let's just fix it
okay right so it's optional yeah yeah
let's fix that all right so okay let's
come back to the original question right
so let's imagine that we had this notion
of elementary evaluate right and what
does elementary evaluate really do okay
what it really does is it sprays various
kinds of assumptions it has a it has a
list of things it does it puts
assumptions into solve
now I don't know whether is it enough to
wrap and assuming around everything or
does that not correctly you know seep
into things both we just talked about
soul doesn't have a size no I know
that's a bug am I gonna fix it okay that
it's just a bug okay so let's keep going
we you know assume that that's been
fixed does assuming seep into all of
these functions or not I think it's it's
needs something more complicated because
it's it actually needs to use to use
certain rules rather than assume that
something so if you if you have you
don't make an assumption of on X if you
have like square root of 1 minus x
squared the new [ __ ] should actually
assume that 1 minus X is positive okay
so hold on hold on hold on what you're
saying is it's not enough okay so wait a
minute so some variables know yeah hold
on hold on the only question what about
Auto evaluations so so that's a lot big
deal that Stephen has been pointing out
here I typed his in and it doesn't come
out the way I want it to come out right
so it's not going to be good and i
assuming right now does not interact
with auto evaluation right um possibly
it should
mmm okay so that that's a different
issue right should assuming you know
effect auto evaluation should we make
auto evaluation of spelling would able
to go to an opinion auto evaluation
spelling word not a spelling would know
you say not a spelling word not the
spelling word but a spacing
okay um okay so that's a question what
why are you responding negatively to
that Roger I I think that what in in
reality I think we would basically sin
implement is right now with a simplifier
that runs on every evaluation okay that
would slow the system down quite well I
mean given that you rap assuming around
it then that's what you're doing I mean
a written refine okay assuming refined
which is just sort of kind of like a
cheaper simplify yes
I can't I'm trying to predict what the
consequences are and I'm not entirely
sure fair enough I mean we do have a
okay obviously by the way another
mechanism right um
pointed out by Ethan on the live stream
is um you know set dollar assumptions to
something it's actually actually the
same as exactly the same you know I know
I know I know I know I know but let's
say we say dollar assumptions equals
quotes elementary or some such other
thing right ah
but obviously if that's going to work it
sumption 's have got to effect auto
evaluation and that's a big mess right
so that would mean that setting that
global variable would cause even auto
evaluation
to do something which is probably wrong
right so I don't think that's gonna work
okay so what we're left with is the
concept of an elementary evaluate yes I
think that elementary evaluates you know
it's kind of your name for the
simplifier that runs young it's not just
a simplify Roger book has got to seep
into ya so it's gonna set some mo I mean
I think potentially this corner
elementary could be kind of an
alternative to these other domains that
we have there now that's sort of a one
word right you know I want to understand
your square root of 1 minus x squared
example Adam please right so if you fit
a square root of 1 minus x squared go to
1 minus X all squared under under square
root so yep and then what and 1 minus X
in parentheses
ok so assuming assuming that X is
greater than a enough right okay so this
is what this is what I was hoping we
would get to in this meeting is what is
what is the axiomatic system of
elementary math so it's I would say it's
more that certain certain that also are
always true and also of course it's not
consistent then okay do we have that
list do we have it do we have it you
know we need a characterization of what
the axiomatic system of elementary math
is and
and then how will we even tell it if we
wanted this to be simplified how would
we get that to happen in the current
system a power expand would do it that's
what I'm saying power expand is not self
consistent and there's no simple way of
saying what power power expands just a
great big hammer yeah how much similar
to the one I'm asking for now exactly
and so the rules use my power expand or
not but it can't be listed you see do
you see what it did here right yeah it's
it's if you wanted to see the domains
for X for which this is valid it's it
was different then some other power
expand right or you can understand it as
apply your rules
don't don't don't worry about me so it
doesn't have doesn't require that the
outfit Cisco is equivalent to the input
right right right
there's no there's no guarantee that
power X band is a simplify well because
simplify attempts to make it make the
output mathematically equal to the input
the power X band is not right
um fair enough
okay so power expand is one of the
important things that we've already
built in 1991 for you know to achieve
the kinds of things we're talking about
now so we need a generalization of this
basically so that to it so I think we
are you know we're I think we've got a
sort of meta plan here that we've got
some kind of elementary evaluate or some
such other thing that's first point that
it will have a certain set of rules we
should probably be able to parameterize
its rules as a second argument by with
various kinds of string names boy this
is a this is a thing that I obsessed
about in SMP was being able to have rule
sets that you could switch in or out and
one of the profound profound I don't
know one of the conclusions was nobody
cared right so the idea was you could
take some you know book of mathematical
tables and you could say this is the a
thing for a very limited set people can
no doubt so we did plot themes and I
insist on us having very few but very
consistently done yet if you go and look
we you know so I think we're at eight or
something eight standard things that
always work yeah yeah I mean I remember
he literally hundreds of settings that
you don't know about if you go and drill
in and people will not know them what do
you mean they're hundreds of settings
you mean those de la zine has hundreds
of settings that people do not know
because you have to look perf unction
what is some particularly nice thing for
this function and there is something
there which you see in the autocomplete
for instance you might see them in their
autocomplete
if you don't send me any autocomplete
they might as well not exist
why don't you see them in the hotel I'm
not sure I would have to kind of do an
example and see if they're there because
often there's kind of secondary they
modify some things in a main theme what
theme but I think I mean how would you
ever know that what what why do we say a
document that they're you know if you go
to you know I don't know pic there is
like vector plot or a plot or something
like that at the end there are some
settings for plot theme that are unique
to that one
that are listed right and they solve a
problem they all solve some problem that
people have come to us with right but
look at this this this was the this was
the scheme for SNP right that's SNP code
and that was so that the idea was that
was a package and that gives names to
rule sir yeah I gives names although
some dos are the names say de dólar is
Zeta 2 and so on yeah I think it might
be an S but I'm not sure and that you
know that's that's the book Magnus
overhead ginger and Sony I think page 23
right so this was a total fail I
understand why it's it's super hard I
mean you have to you have to be very
engaged and yes and by the time you're
that engaged you're probably typing I
mean the main thing this is saving you
is not typing it in again right
but and maybe in modern times with you
know because this was before gooeys
right so there was no notion of an
autocomplete or anything like that I
mean in modern times dollar is dollar
that under current variable yeah
underscore um and that's uh that's
question mark I guess um but um
we don't even have that's natural number
Q I think except we don't have that we
do her boss
integers Oh negative integers yeah we
don't have a Q function do we uh no oh
gosh that's pathetic that's young
tableau we still don't have young
tableau you know anyway let's not get
into which things we still don't have
here we have Whitacre functions don't we
yes um anyhow okay but but anyway so
this idea of of you know named hum um
boy I should go through and check that
we actually have all these functions now
this time flight and collect successive
sets of n entries and listen to so
that's partition unfunded sounds like it
right the okay in a case um okay that's
actually interesting suggestion from as
for us H our live stream nice thing the
students will be for solve and so on -
somehow point out what assumptions have
been made that is an interesting point
is there any way we could get so in
other words if you use elementary
evaluate can it collect some that is in
fact what that's the thing that you
didn't want does which thing I didn't
want you know saw the answers that had
the conditions on X for which this is
this yes okay fair enough fair enough
fair point right so you're saying so the
question is should there be a way for
elementary evaluate to return with them
to return with a wrapper that
as its conditions but that's that's
obviously the way that it should do it
is with a conditional expression I would
think probably there should be a way to
get that back as some method for
elementary evaluator whatever else it is
which which possibly the the suggestions
bar could could suggest you do in other
words if you want to know what
assumptions were made
eg after you get a result the
suggestions bar could suggest you rerun
you know with that with the assumptions
keeper okay well look it seems to me the
next thing to do here is inventory what
is this axiom system basically and go
think about it because we I don't think
we've I think we've only got to about
one third of the things that have to be
thought about that yeah
um I think it's a it's a bunch of rules
I don't think it's an axiom I just think
that they're fine change tranquil
transformation rules right yeah okay but
okay fine so that's the first thing
second thing is the actual UX of
elementary evaluate okay I mean one
thing that's obviously coming is the one
thing if you just do it there's no
problem for it to do to deal with what
okay men no you wanted order to
evaluation I will soon say there's no
penalty if you always have it apply just
when you do it because then you have a
reason to want it
and and that little extra cost it's not
a big deal if it's gonna penalize
everything in the entire system all the
time it starts to be a little bit of a
problem well then what are you saying I
mean you're saying look the issue is go
ahead what are you gonna say I was
saying that support of it is that it
sort of sets up kind of like a mode
basically like assumptions like you know
state of some kind I would think of as
long as a lexical mechanism that is
particularly if it's rewriting code well
I don't know if it's lexical right
question actually is it lexical dynamic
I think it's not economic but I think it
has to be dynamic yes but but the other
thing is that you just have an
expression let's say square root of x
squared you know and you want it under
elementary evaluation it has to do some
simplification as to modify out behaves
but if you wrap if you run if you if you
if you wrap alimentary evaluate around
it the fact that you pay a little bit to
get that is not a problem you're asked
for it right sure but so if you wrap it
right but I mean the point is look the
issue that we have is for advanced users
wrapping it particular if it's on the
suggestions bar if it's an enhanced way
in the suggestions bar is not a problem
okay oh it's for users who understand
what's going on but just don't like like
you know my example of that solving that
that you know ultimately you know that
that power equation you know their head
down below so to speak mmm the
okay the question is for genuinely
elementary users what do we do right now
I would argue we might tell them use
WolframAlpha notebook Edition if you
want of course then and that's that's an
issue for bird and Jeremy and so on you
know it we got to make this work in that
but hopefully we can use this technology
there or however else we do it but I
mean so I'm saying I mean in other words
if you were genuine a non-tree user and
you you really really don't want to see
the evils of complex numbers and so on
you know this is probably a good
interface for you again it's probably
more a question for cliff and so and I
don't really know you know all their
users who want to use pure Mathematica
for example but only wants it to be
operating in elementary mode hard to
know that's a question for cliff and
somebody should ask him maybe Isabel can
make a note there um okay so question um
the other thing that does happen and
it's kind of unavoidable but you know we
can might as well bring it up is that
even with elementary input you can get
very much beyond the elementary output
from solvers in particular indeed and is
this like no I mean short of not
answering no I think it's fine I don't
think I've never seen you know people
type in some integral they thought it
was trivial they made a typo you know it
turns out to be you know ten lines of
error you know of you know poly
logarithms or something right so what
don't worry about it
okay I mean the only that I don't think
that's a problem for anybody go ahead in
alpha when things are kind of
sufficiently complicated looking
containing root objects for whatever
oftentimes we just knew Mary sighs and
and that's you know having the actual
number is a useful thing that people can
do something with so we you saw we
changed the typesetting of route
objects to do to sort of basically
display that and yes you know people
react differently to change but I would
say that apart from one or two algebraic
number theory people everybody loves it
yeah I can see why there's right number
theory people don't like it right I do
too
um yeah it's kind of annoying for them I
wonder whether that's a way to I wonder
whether we should have a form an
algebraic number form that will display
without that what do you think yeah it's
possible
let's let's look at that put it into
aisle the meeting and discuss it um okay
but but now the question is with the
elementary evaluate possibility dollar
pre equals elementary evaluate basically
it's what we're talking about I think
that with the new toolbar new notebook
toolbar we could imagine having it be
generically the case that one can set a
preprocessor in other words that the
value of dollar pre could be set in the
notebook toolbar and that that's a that
we could have a whole menu like themes
basically of settings for dollar pre in
the notebook toolbar and that might be
the solution to this
since everybody by the time they're
running um you know by the time somebody
is not running in a notebook front end
you know they're not an elementary user
I mean that's in terms of signals for
elementary usage that is one definitive
signal if they're running you know in a
row Linux kernel whatever you know not
not iris you um so what do you think
about that Roger this I think it sounds
potentially interesting I mean I'm still
I want to spend some time with Adam and
and and maybe address on this call to
see if we can actually
make it consistent enough that we can do
it without causing horrible fine but
then so I think then the the temper the
the tentative idea would be um that you
know um add a dollar prix theme to the
notebook toolbar and by the way that has
to be communicated to I just thought of
another idea and people hate our list
representation of matrices for people
that do linear algebra it's just the
wrong thing um so that's another one of
those actually fine fine I mean so maybe
there's a maybe that's a you know maybe
there's a whole notion of themes you
know display and evaluation themes in
the notebook toolbar okay so can that
get communicated to on the user user
assistance folk um maybe we should have
this because they're gonna have a bunch
a question and we don't have anything to
give them
maybe we should proceed a little bit
farther before we well no but the idea
the reason I'm bringing that up is
because the design of the Knoblauch
toolbar is in motion right now oh yeah I
know okay and so the issue is that we
basically need to leave a space for an
evaluation theme is what it comes down
to I like this idea actually
I think this would give us an
opportunity because then you know you
can as a matter of the stylesheet
you could then set you know have a
different setting for the menu of
evaluation themes and that's a way to to
control a bunch of things without having
you know I think a global variable that
you see it in your toolbar is a lot less
problematic now okay so the issue then
is I see so then the real question is
what is the default default that is when
you start a new notebook what does it do
and I suspect that's the thing that I
mean that that thing gets into another
whole can of worms about like setting
that in installer and so on because well
I think we have I mean it's like well
what do you want to run with you want to
run with that help suggestions bar on or
off you set that globally for a session
or for multi session see them and I
think isn't it the same thing here
yes probably I see so what you're saying
is I see I see so this is just going
into the persistence okay so this this
could be stored in in your global in
your global um persistence location
which I mean when I start a new notebook
it doesn't come with a suggestions bar
cuz I've turned it off I understand but
but we now have this whole notion of
persistence locations which will go
across different you know the Machine
your whole account the cloud or even
more global great yes right so that's
the right thing so basically basically
what can happen is in the in the menu
that sets this you can decide what you
know when you set it you can decide
whether you want to set it really
globally I mean I suspect that there's a
there will be a desire in some
educational settings for example that
the installer actually sets this for
people but that's different issue again
maybe those people that's a cliff
question maybe those people should be
using WolframAlpha notebook Edition and
not this if they're that keen to to you
know you know not see complex numbers so
to speak um that's wsh on our on our
live stream is saying themed repository
yeah a second idea but I'm gonna make a
note of that actually um it certainly
seems like to me if if a school district
was using our technologies broadly right
there's there's a case for the classes
that start with just Wayne but I think
that I think that there is a place for
either on the classroom level or a grade
level having like you're describing
having having a whole class that you
know individual students don't have to
go and set this themselves that it's
okay you know the right way to do that
though the right way to do that is that
with this thing that we're also talking
about for from alpha which is this class
linked cloud system where basically
every login that where you know where a
teacher can basically set something that
says produce results without complex
numbers and that
that can be done through a century
through the cloud through the login
system for those particular users I mean
I feel a little bit it's like one of
these things like like you know changing
Geographic maps because somebody doesn't
want you to know that some country is
there or some such other thing I mean
it's a little bit shocking in some ways
to be able to do that but I think I
think nobody thinks that that term the
the banishment of complex numbers is is
as controversial so to speak it's it's
learning Newtonian physics before
relativity or something yeah
I mean that could argue that complex
numbers may not even be needed so um
we're there yeah ok should we are we are
we pretty much done however I'm just um
comments with locally deployable themes
yeah no I agree this locally deployable
themes thing is a good idea right it's
some um the UM okay anything else for
this meeting um nope all right so let's
let's circle back as they say can we get
this notebook yep you see this is what
you get for running basically project I
can send it out Stephen okay great
um okay sounds good all right that was
productive thank you very much and thank
you to folks on the livestream for a
bunch of good suggestions actually we
have one more thing coming here let's
see what's being said in case it's the
most important thing of the day no it
isn't okay great thanks a lot guys see
you another time